let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
good afternoon everybody
welcome to let's talk the tony michaels
podcast episode number
six we have a great one
for you today we have a guest today that
is going to tell us
all about the wackadoos and q anon
that's not how he puts it that's how i
put it
but he's going to give us his insight
and his professional
view of what q anon is and how it can be
unlocked or if it can be unlocked
frankly and how that all looks in our
country
so there's a couple different stories
that i want to talk about first before
we get into our guest
and i'll be uh i'll introduce him here
in a second
um he's with us on the other line here
but uh there's a couple stories i want
to get to
uh before we start digging into q anon
and how to uncross the wires that these
people
uh have crossed in their brains and in
the country and
can can we figure out a way can we
figure out a way to
to help these people or is there helping
them you know let's let's we're going to
unpack that today
but the first thing i want to talk about
here is um
someone passed away today his name is
rush limbaugh
you people have probably heard of this
[ __ ] uh
he was a radio host for a couple years
on a insignificant
talk radio show this
this this [ __ ] had a lot of influence
on this country for a long
time and he used his obvious talent for
not
anything good a lot of bad a lot i used
to listen to rush limbaugh
uh almost every day until he really
decided to
uh dive deep into the cheeto universe of
donald trump
and uh it was the same disgusting stuff
every day and i couldn't take it anymore
so i stopped listening russian ball
and most the days that i listened to
russian ball i would completely be
yelling and screaming
at the radio because i vehemently
disagree with almost every single word
this guy said
i just find it very ironic that the
person who is on the radio spewing lines
to the american people about how
uh cigarettes and tobacco do not cause
cancer and they do not kill you
uh he died from lung cancer today so
good luck wrestling ball and and good
luck to whoever who takes up his mantle
um so the other the other significant
news today was uh
the casino in atlantic city uh trump taj
mahal or whatever the hell it's called i
don't remember
um i know it doesn't really matter uh we
got to see this thing imploded
on video today which was freaking
fantastic i might say it is uh
it is great it is great to watch donald
trump lose an election
it is great to watch him get impeached
twice even though he was
he wasn't convicted there's still 57
votes to uh
to convict this guy obvious obviously
the majority of the country is not
is not behind this trumpism uh even
though we have a large population that
still is but it is
it i just have to say this it is such a
great day to watch
trump tower fall to the complete ground
uh
and just a day after he writes this
letter to
to try to uh eviscerate mitch mcconnell
as if this is a good thing for trumpism
like they're not on the run that they
have to attack their own leaders in
their own party
which kind of leads me to what we're
going to talk about today
uh is how infiltrated is on inside the
republican party and can it be reversed
or is it just a thing that's going going
to exist
you know and going to exist for the long
haul uh you know
i don't i don't know if that's if that's
how we can expect this to keep going or
if we're going to if we're going to
actually
watch this thing melt down because we do
have the march 4th thing coming up
you know they keep going about march 4th
march 4th march 4th
which you know this day will pass
apparently trump hotel in dc has
raised their rates because all these
trumpledites are
are booking rooms at the trump dc hotel
so
they're paying four times the cost on
their orange deities
hotels so they can go do whatever it is
that they're
i don't know what they're planning on
doing i guess standing out in front of
his hotel with their flags i have no
idea
it should be very interesting but um but
you know
this this q and on question is is a
complex one i think
um you know i truly believe that that
the q anon stuff has been that this
mantle of tune on has been taken up by
some of these white supremacists
and some of these white supremacists
that live inside evangelical
christianity
a white evangelical christianity to be
exact and they dispose these white
supremacist ideas they've taken up q
on that they've used it as their voice
to
have this thin veil of supremacy
so you know forever they called it the
alt-right
and that branding didn't work and we'll
get into that here in a minute so they
rebranded his q anon
and it's a lot easier to sell this
garbage uh to people who want to believe
it that don't want to think that they're
that they're white supremacist but
that's just my personal belief
but we have someone on the podcast today
that has a little bit of
a professional experience in psychosis
and
i call it whack-a-doo you know because i
like to use words like that because
they're funny
but he uses different words he uses
those professional words
which is good because i want to ask him
about those words and what the hell they
mean
uh he did a video a while back on um
on psychosis and mass psychosis and and
how this stuff
affects mass groups of people and what
to expect
but he's on tick tock so he only gets 60
[ __ ] seconds to say this stuff
so i said hey man i want you to come on
and give us more than 60 seconds of your
knowledge
like you can drop it let's drop it on a
on a platform that's a hell of a lot
longer than 60 seconds
so let me play you a clip the video that
i think
i think is the question that a lot of
people are asking themselves right now
about q anon and trumpism
uh make america great again white
supremacy in this country that this
video
kind of asks the question and he doesn't
have time to really answer it
so we're going to let him answer it on
the other side of this when i introduce
him but here's the video that i seen a
matt d
so trump's out of office we've got a new
president and yet if your world's
anything like mine
you're still dealing with the effects on
your family your friends your co-workers
what we're dealing with is known as
shared psychosis which is a
disorder that is characterized by the
sharing of psychotic symptoms between
two or more people the inducer trump the
induced
his supporters so how this happens is
someone delusional and paranoid like
trump gets in an influential position
and forges emotional bond with his
supporters and then passes his symptoms
on
through that bond through prolonged
exposure to his delusions and his
paranoia
these previously healthy people um
become
deluded paranoid and perhaps even uh
taking on his propensity towards
violence
here's the good news the way to treat
shared psychosis is to remove
exposure and that's happened he's off
twitter he's out of office not in the
spotlight as much
most who've been infected will make a
full recovery you might even be seeing
that but what about the ones who have
continued to devolve even further
well they're gonna have their own
separate videos so stay tuned
all right hey matt how are you buddy hey
how's it going tony i'm doing good
thanks for having me on
so that video uh answers a lot are
asked a lot more questions than it
answers because you only got 60 seconds
um i think that's why you were gonna do
a second video but
so today we're i'm gonna ask you a bunch
of questions about this and we're gonna
talk about it
and we had a chance to discuss this
earlier um and you had a lot of good
insight on this but
tell us a little bit about yourself and
why the hell we should listen to a guy
like you
about stuff like this right so um
so i have a graduate degree in
psychology um
i am licensed to practice psychotherapy
um and i have advanced training in
body-centered psychotherapy i've worked
in
uh community mental health clinics and
the criminal justice system
counseling people working with some
pretty difficult populations working
with people who do have psychosis
and i currently run a successful uh
private psychotherapy practice so you
could say that my world is
um very much uh made up of psychology
awesome awesome so so so the question
that you pose in there
uh because again i i call it all these
funny words i say they're looney tunes
or wackadoos
um you know and and part of that is to
get the laughs
uh you know but but uh to to to talk
a little bit about it without having
their expense in it
um these people do have mental health
problems i mean uh
is it every single one of them can we
just say
can we just say oh this is a mental
health thing and that's all it is or is
it beyond
is it a little more beyond of just
mental health state this psychosis that
you caught and then explain this
right right so that's beyond and yeah
let's get that out of the way that there
is um so there is your trump supporter
right that is about practicality
over morality what they're interested in
is their wallet
trump was good for them whatever and
they don't care about all the other
stuff so
that might even be the majority of trump
supporters but then you have you know so
those were people that
um weren't emotionally bonded they
didn't forge
trump wasn't able to forge that
emotional bond with them
so but you have other people that were
that were for whatever reason
needy needed to connect in an emotional
way with somebody
with an authoritarian person and they
did and once that happens
uh trump can pass on his
uh psychosis to the person through that
bond
and basically what psychosis is to
answer your question is it's just um
it's sort of uh an alternate reality
right people that are are living in uh
this something has gone wrong their
wires have been crossed
in their brain tony to where um
they have delusions and uh
hallucinations and it can take on all
sorts of forms i could talk about it
endlessly so i'll
we'll cut it right there so so let me
ask you
see you said they they you know i i like
to say they get their
wires crossed and i guess that's a good
way of uh describing it
um when you don't know when when you're
ignorant like me of the actual
professional terms
uh you know i i like to say it that way
because i i truly think that
that that not all these people had their
wires crossed the entire time there was
something events that happened because
you say bonding like they're bonding
with donald trump
so but a lot of this don't i mean do you
do you think that uh because a lot of
people want to blame it on social media
did they gain that bond through social
media because a lot of these people did
not go physically to a rally and see him
um they just seen him on video or
something so does that bond
can that bond happen even virtually yes
yes yes and so there's been research
done here
um that where they had you know trump's
or they just had
political i'm i'm forgetting the exact
study but basically i'll give you a
breakdown of what it was
they hooked people's brains up to a
machine like an fmri so they can study
electrical impulses in their brains and
then they showed them different
politicians
and donald trump like these people's
brains like
something about trump uh just took their
attention right
he's something about him would just uh
grab their attention very quickly and so
this is
sort of uh and that was they're just
looking at it virtually right that's not
them being with him in person
so there was something about trump where
he was really able to
get these people to respond and to
respond in a significant way
so so do you think it's his hair no i'm
just kidding i'm just kidding
um so so um
i'll i'll give you i'll give you that
that he does have a high intensity of
response even with just images of him
uh i think i think i think it's not just
people who support him i think it's
people who don't support him as well
uh you know he's a very interesting
uh physically being i mean
you know he obviously he obviously has
his signature
signature hair his signature ties
signature suits
he all he's he's almost like a cartoon
character in that you don't see him in
any other state
um i think that's why some of the
pictures of him really piss him
off uh personally because they're
outside of what his character you know
he's
he's always had this brand he always
wants this character that he has
and and it's pretty consistent do you
think that
coupled with like um you know he's very
he was very famous before he started
running for president
uh and and he gained a lot of popularity
with the conservative movement
uh through his birtherism about barack
obama i mean do you think that's where
some of that bonding comes from
is uh sure whose ideas are sure
sure absolutely in those ideas and
um donald trump is one of these people
that just exudes uh whether it's real or
not he exudes
confidence right he really does have a
magnetic personality
uh in in that magnetic you know could
push you away from him or pull you
towards him
and he was really able to take a whole
bunch of people
who were not feeling so uh
wonderful about themselves and he's able
to sort of prop them
up inside this grandiose way of being
so let's talk about that for a second
because i wanna i want to switch
gears here and take the focus off donald
trump and more about
the the people who uh followed him in
this q anon because
do you think do you think trumpism and q
anon are the same thing
um or do you think that that those the q
anon aspect of it
and and some of those conspiracy
theories are separate from trump
and they just feel his base or how do
how do you think that correlates to
you know this this obsession with him
and the bond that they have i mean where
does that oh
how does the q anon stuff play into it
well so it
i'm not a q a historian but i do
um i do remember like when when i heard
about q anon
it really started as these pro-trump
conspiracy theories
so i think that they are enmeshed
together now that doesn't mean that like
uh if you're a trumper or you're uh into
trumpism that you're definitely into
cueing on
but and again this isn't a scientific
finding here
but i wouldn't be surprised if you know
you were much
more likely to be involved in q anon if
you were also
involved in trumpism so
so let me ask you then do you think that
uh because my my assumption is and this
is just my
my view of it because again i know i
know q and on expert either and i don't
think we'll know this for several years
until we really unpack
how this happened um because there's a
lot to unpack from
this q anon conspiracy theory but let's
let's
my assumption is is that it started off
as this
you know a couple people talking about
conspiracy theories
on twitter or anywhere at 8chan or for
channels
right right right whatever these places
are these these these
these message boards are reddit and i
believe that it was kind of just just to
get attention
and it started to catch on and my view
of it is is
that the right wing was really looking
for a rebranding because
after charlottesville they went to
charlottesville they held torches it was
a bunch of white dudes
you know basically yelling in the
streets jews will not replace us
and and conservatives in this country
like oh my gosh no you can't because you
know trump even said both sides thing
and
that we we did that whole thing where we
basically said
alt-right is not good right and and that
what that step
brand stuck with them so the alt-right
was looking for this way to work its way
inside of
white christianity in this country
evangelicals to be specific
and they use q anon to kind of program
themselves and have this thin
veiled uh conspiracy of white supremacy
to convince religious people
that that it's party it's part of you or
or something you know
i don't know how this works i i really
don't even believe in conspiracy
theories i
honestly truly believe that lee harvey
oswald shot and killed jfk like
i don't even believe the conspiracy
theories right now so
so i my brain doesn't work in this way
to believe this these things
right um and i think that has a little
bit to do with but do you think there's
a component here of
is it white supremacy is it religion did
they
is religion trying to use this is this
are are these q anon beliefs and these
people who believe this q and stuff
is it their religion that pre-programs
to believe this type of stuff
i mean that it's a really good question
tony and i
i don't necessarily have the answer
specifically
for that do i think that what you're
saying like do i think
so with q anon it's anonymous right
that's what a non is
and so it's like yeah it could be
anybody it could be anything
everything you're saying it absolutely
could be what i'm certain of
is the people that are pulled towards
conspiracy theory
are pulled towards it because they feel
very unsure of themselves they feel very
insecure
and they believe that this is a way for
them to
have knowledge and have uh certainty
um in an otherwise a world in which they
otherwise don't feel that way
um you know it's also a way and religion
does this too
it prevents them from having to live
into
uh chaos right so religion much like
conspiracy theory
can give you like uh an organized world
view
so you don't feel so uncertain and you
don't feel so
uh insecure so so basically what you're
saying is what these two things
have in common with religion because i
am an atheist so i i don't
i don't have the the faith belief
um uh but i believe that sometimes can
be a detriment to me
and the reason why is because i think
people use religion
in a way that fills the gaps of the
things that they don't know
so if they don't know something they use
their faith which sometimes can be good
for that person's mental health state
to explain it with a face based reason
because then you don't have to actually
know you just have faith right
so do you think that they're filling
some of their some of their reality
holes or or
are they creating holes intentionally to
fill that reality with these
conspiracies and
you know kind of peg those holes closed
with these conspiracy theories to
explain
why they want to believe this stuff or
is it unwitting they just
what do you i mean can you unpack that
yeah so so i think uh
and you know it'll piggyback off of what
i was just saying i i
and so i think they are filling holes
and i think really i
they have a desire the p so people that
are involved in q and on and conspiracy
theories
they have a desire to feel uh unique
or a desire to feel superior and that's
both individually
and uh at the group level so they would
have um you know they have inside
information right that's what q anon is
it's all this inside information that
they have that you and i don't have
tony so that means that basically you
and me are sheep
and that person is on the inside right
and so and right
so in that way they feel superior and
then look at that at the group level too
right
if you're in q anon q anon is like all
knowing and moral right there they have
a big morality thing right because
you and i again we are just uh passive
observers in this crazy cabal
of pedophilia that is going on
underneath our noses
and so they're superior and again we are
the sheep
and so i think it really fulfills a
psychological need again to be unique
and to feel uh special and there is a
huge
um narcissistic element to it as well
so speaking of that and and how it kind
of relates
and and kind of looks like because it
looks like religion
is it looks like religion but
is it is it is it more than just their
their individual faith as into is there
a component of it where they have to
feel like they're a part of something do
you think that's the trumpism of it
or is it i mean is that separate from
the q anon
because again these things because i i
know people personally
who will tell me i don't believe in that
q9 stuff that stuff's crazy
and then you ask them about individual
things you're like of course i believe
that of course i believe that i'm like
that's
that's queuing on like that's exactly
what they're saying right so
right and i think the problem is um and
we talked about this earlier
about social media and algorithms and
it's i believe that algorithms are
garbage in garbage out
everyone wants to blame the algorithm
for feeding us bad things
but the algorithm only feeds us what we
want to see
right the algorithm is artificial
intelligence that's
feeding us the garbage because we want
the garbage we want it
so is is there some innate desire for
these people because they want to feel
like they're part of a group
that the religion aspect because i
believe that's a lot of religion because
i
i know a lot of people that go to church
but they're not very religious
right it's just a matter of i like to go
and get dressed up and be part of the
group
and be and be accepted as part of the
group
so is it is q anon and trumpism separate
in that way are they kind of the same or
tell me more about like is it an
acceptance thing or isn't it
as a group or as an individual thing see
so
so again i think it's both right i think
it's um it's fulfilling a need on both
levels to feel
important special unique both
as an individual and oh my group is that
way too
and yes um religion is very much
like that as well so um and actually the
fellowship
that happens among in religions is one
of the
um i would say good things about
religion
meaning that you know there's all sorts
of research that shows
that being part of you know you um just
on your average normal religion
uh and being a part of that religion is
gonna most people live longer if they
are part
of that sort of uh fellowship and that
just goes back to yeah feeling like they
belong
so now q anon if so if we want to go i
guess we could say and i haven't thought
this through tony so i'm just putting
this out there now
i guess we could say that q anon could
be a psychotic
very twisted form of religion okay well
that makes sense i i mean
so what you're saying about the
fellowship is that
it's not necessarily um
that's not a state of the psychosis it's
just
that's that's what helps someone through
the psychosis is that fair
to say or okay okay so so now that we
know
what this is and we'll never know for
sure you know i i mean i i think that's
the
the the hardest part is this stuff lives
out on the the internet
and it's hard for us to determine which
of them are actually seriously believing
this stuff
and which of these are just agging it on
um
and you know they're being internet
trolls or they're lurkers or whatever is
actually happening
you know some people are intentionally
stoking the fire i remember
uh one of the theories before january
20th before the inauguration was the
face-off theory
right and and it really at at first i'm
like
there's no way that these people
actually believe it
but then i thought it's probably someone
who trolled
on these forums and said hey no they're
going to switch their faces
and because they saw it on a forum and a
couple people that they knew picked it
up
that they started to believe this thing
just like this march 4 thing so are you
aware of the march 4th thing
of what they're well let me see so first
of all you just blew me away wait you're
saying they didn't trade faces
oh yeah they did not no they didn't
they they did not they did not do the
nicholas cage john
they did not do that what's what's
really what what really
blows my mind about that theory is that
only a couple weeks later there's
actually a story about
a guy who had one of the first
successful fl
face transplants he actually he was a
burn victim and he literally had an
actual face transplant
and if you read that story and you read
about how complicated it was to give
that
person uh that actual face transplant
and how
successful it was and why it was
successful you would completely
understand
the critical thinking behind the idea of
them switching faces how
[ __ ] ridiculous it is that joe biden
and donald trump would switch faces
like you would there's no way if you
read the one story first
that you could ever be in a universe
that you could ever consider
that the second story about joe biden
and donald trump's switching faces could
ever
exist outside a science fiction movie
right um it's just on his face it's
crazy
right but this is where we're at i mean
it's the same thing about this march 4th
thing
and i think that's why they attach
themselves to these little things that
seem like they can be true
and is there something to them like
moving the goal post is that part of
conspiracy is that part of psychosis
like is that part of
the mental health state that they're in
or or is that just is that just
something that they're doing
that the leaders of this movement who
are monetizing it because let's face it
there are people who are monetizing this
is that what they're doing just to
continue to monetize monetize this thing
right
so it absolutely would be a part of
um psychosis in that
these people um keep believing
outlandish
like completely unreal things right it's
not just
um you know who killed kennedy
type of thing like some of this stuff
gets really crazy like democrats being
lizard people
right so now you're talk you're talking
about actual delusions at that point
right the other important thing you
brought up that i want to just circle
back to for a second when you were
mentioning the face off thing and if
they actually
were able to look at real information so
that's another hallmark of q and on and
conspiracy theories in general is that
most
people that buy into these things have a
lower iq and it doesn't mean they're not
smart it doesn't mean they're stupid
it just means they were never given the
tools to be able to
to critically think or to accurately
source information
and so the information that they're
getting is really
they believe it's superior right they
believe that this is
the truth and they have no other way to
to look up that
uh face transplant situation that you
were that you were talking about that
would make them go
oh you know so that's another part of it
and then moving the goal post yeah i
think you bring up an important point
about them monetizing it
and it's also the other part here is
that they eat up
the moving of the goal post because
they're so desperate for this to keep
going because if it stops if they have
to drop into
like so they have all sorts of
psychological defense mechanisms
triggered inside of them to not uh
see how deceived they have been to not
feel how duped they have been
and so they are going to welcome they're
going to eat up any sort of moving of
the goal post
when say january 6 doesn't happen right
or
or march 4th doesn't happen they're
going to feel like [ __ ] and they're
going to be
looking for something else to latch onto
so you're saying are you saying in that
respect cause because
um i guess what i'm hearing you say is
it's easier for them to explain away
[ __ ] that doesn't happen that they say
is gonna happen
that is [ __ ] ridiculous just on its
face like this march 4th thing is
absolutely right the january 6th thing
was
on its face was crazy so was the the
inauguration than this march 4 thing
but are you saying that it's easier for
them in their psychosis
to to say oh well it didn't happen
because of this reason just come up with
some other deluded reason
or than it is to just admit that hey
this is all a delusion
is that what you're saying that it's
easier to keep getting more delusions
than just say
it is a [ __ ] delusion right right so
the hallmark of psychosis
is right is the psychotic person doesn't
they can develop insight into their
symptoms
but a big hallmark of it is they don't
know right the psychotic person is
living in an alternate reality
and their perception is that their
reality is real
and ours is the alternative reality
right so it's just it's really important
to know
that the you know 9.9 times out of 10
the psychotic person has no awareness
and no insight that they
are deluded or psychotic in any way
so we keep talking about like it's an
individual thing
but the problem that i think that we
have here is that they're
it's it's and i don't think it's a large
percent i mean
some people would consider it a large
percentage of the population but i don't
think there's a large percentage of the
population that actually sees themselves
as q anon now as i said before i think a
lot of people believe this garbage who
don't
identify as q or q anon or whatever the
hell it is
um but there is a large number of people
that's i think the problem here is
there's a large number of people that
identify as
as q and honor or believe or have this
psychosis
so it what is the component
because we've been talking about
individualism right and individuals
having this psychosis
so what the hell is the component there
to have this mass psychosis
because that i think is the thing
because because individual psychosis
as you call it or i call them wackadoos
individually
they're not they're not a threat to our
uh democracy
but on a large scale it is obvious that
they can cause
a lot of concern for our democracy so
how did we get there like is there
something about the conspiracy theories
like cult like
everyone says the word cult so is there
something there that gives them
this you know to do this on a mass scale
and have
you know hundreds of thousands of people
believing this
absolute nonsense right so
humanon right absolutely q anon i think
does
fit the criteria for being a cult
um now that might be where your social
media and stuff comes in like how it was
able to
reach such a large audience of people
some of the factors we've already talked
about you know a large swath
of our country not knowing how to
source accurate information i think uh
also this the pandemic plays into this
in that a lot of people went online who
previously were not
online right they were doing other
things even the older population
especially
going online finding youtube right like
youtube university kind of stuff
hey don't knock youtube we're on it
right now no i'm just kidding
well no i'm not what i'm saying is
people can use that you could fall into
a youtube wormhole
you could find anything on youtube right
right it's kind of garbage in garbage
out like i was talking earlier
right right so um and also i think it's
really important to say this
a psychotic person or even a group of
psychotic people
is no more or less dangerous than a than
a healthy person or a group of healthy
people
the only time when it gets dangerous
is if uh a criminal element is
introduced
right so you could have a bunch of
psychotic people
and you could tell them you know go to
the holy land and pray
and whatever and that's fine but then if
you start telling them to fight
you start telling them to be violent
that's the problem so
psychosis in and of itself is not
violent and that's actually
um a real big misconception in
sort of general society that i felt like
was important to say
so where were you during the trials of
the insurrection if uh
if if telling these people to go to go
fight is uh
when it turns violent i i think that's i
you know unpack that a little bit
because um
i don't know that all the
insurrectionists were would identify as
q anon but they definitely seen trump as
their leaders so
in this in this cultish thing that we're
talking about if it is a cult
who is the cult leader is the cult
leader trump or is the cult leader q
and and who gives the orders and who
i mean because because generally in a
cult you have a
authoritarian leader right yes and then
you listen to that leader
right which trump does fall under that
definition right he is an authoritarian
he is a leader um but he is not
claiming you know explicitly that this
is my
my cult it could be uh
q right but nobody knows who q is people
think maybe trump is q
or what it gets it gets pretty uh pretty
intense
but really what what's happening is i
think it's important to
maybe even differently than a cult it's
not uh
it might be better see because when you
look at it when you when you put colt on
it right like
people do really kind of curl away from
that and if we are
looking to bridge any sort of gap right
to make
uh to promote healing in any way
we we might we might not want to shout
that from the rooftops
instead we might say things like these
people have been you know victims of an
abusive relationship
right because i really feel like what
you've seen
with q and on and with trump and if we
if we say that they are
uh leader 1a and leader 1b
is that there has been a lot of
deception a lot of manipulation
a lot of uh mind hijacking from both of
those things
which is the same uh stuff as if you
have a relationship between two people
and one of those people is the abuser
and one of them is the abused
an abusive relationship it has all the
hallmarks all the qualities of that
so let's let's talk about the because
you mentioned
you know healing and getting their
mental state uh
in a better position um is this a thing
where we can just
uh you know just call these people
wackadoos and keep
badgering them are are we do we need
actual physical
mental health care for these people what
can we get them out of the state can we
not get them out of this i mean what's
the answer there to turn this around
right
if this is a problem how do we what's
the solution for the problem
right so here's the main thing right and
i mentioned that in
that the video that you you did sort of
introducing me
is the main thing that happened and i
think you saw
uh the colts if we're going to call it
that we saw it
cut maybe even in half when trump was
removed from office
and left right after january 6
i think a lot of people said okay this
is way too crazy the light bulb went on
and now exposure is way down right trump
doesn't have certain platforms
now to to every day be sort of uh
keeping up that emotional bond
strengthening that emotional bond
so over time things will sort of fade
and i think people will return to health
some people will return to health
other ones tony that's the other thing
is they would need to want help right
the only thing you and i can do is um
maybe try to understand a little bit
more that they're in a tough spot
right they really have been deceived on
a
grand scale and um
yeah there's going to be a lot of pain
inside of them a lot of devastation
inside of them
to really see that to see how if they
can
see how deceived they've been right if
they can get insight
into how um sort of their minds were
polluted
by sort of like the machinations of this
madman trump
so you've treated a lot of people with
psychosis but have you treated anyone
specifically
uh about the cuanon at this point or and
and
and it does it does it does or does that
go into
actually treating someone where you're
specifically pointing out
you know their actual delusions i mean
what is what is the step for healing
these people and i guess my next
question is
is can we force them to heal or do we
just have to stand back and
wait for the light switch to come on
because i've watched the light switch
come on there's that lady that went on
cnn she's on tick-tock now
um and it's and
it almost seems like it is a light
switch like
they have this moment where it's like
boom the light bulb comes on and they're
like oh
all that other stuff that i believed was
completely false
right right and and it doesn't seem like
there's this gradual walk from them
believing delusion and then slowly
walking to not believing delusion
um where the opposite way is it's a slow
walk
to delusion because they bleed these
little nuggets along the way and then
boom they're full on in this rabbit hole
it seems like it doesn't happen that way
and maybe i'm wrong
but it doesn't seem like it happens that
way on the way out it's almost like the
light switch is turned on and
boom they just here it is okay now i
know what the truth is
so how do we unpack that and do we turn
the light bulb on for them
or do we have to wait for them to turn
the light bulb on
okay so because right because there's
been
so much deception and because that would
conspire
with anyone's um psychological defense
mechanism against pain
what ends up happening is uh they're
completely hijacked
in terms of listening to logic or
reasoning right that stuff's not
gonna happen like and that's what i
think of when i when when you say do we
turn the light bulb on
um we're not gonna be able to turn that
light bulb on and really a lot of
attempts for us to turn the light bulb
on
say like oh well check out this and
here's this logic and here's this
argument
um really only pushes them further and
further away from the light bulb
so really it's going to be a lot of
patience and really having firm
boundaries within ourselves
to not follow them into any sort of
rabbit hole so i guess
that's the long and convoluted answer to
they're gonna have to turn the light
bulb on and i think
with time they're gonna move closer and
closer towards a light bulb
and um it's going to turn on others are
just going to
find another conspiracy theory and
they're just getting they're going to
live that way
and they're probably just going to
progress into a deeper and a deeper
uh paranoid deluded way of being and
there's nothing you and i can do to stop
that
so what is what is the danger of that if
we have a
we still have a large number of people
who uh result to that i mean
it is uh with the internet the problem
that i see with this
you call psychosis i call it whackadoos
is uh are looney tunes uh because i
really do think it's a mental health
problem
is that if we have um if we have a bunch
of people that are connecting on the
internet whether it's on facebook or
twitter or 8chan or wherever the hell
these people are gathering up
um if there's enough of them uh can they
be actually physically dangerous or is
this a situation
where the dangerous people are
manipulating the people right that are
the sheep here
i mean because not all these people are
sheep some of these people are
intentionally
making up this information to convince
other people of this like jim jones
didn't believe all the garbage he spewed
in jonestown
he did it for his own gain his own
personal
power his own personal lust for that
power over
other human beings um but he knew
that [ __ ] wasn't true and the reason why
is because in the end
he killed himself and that's why he
wanted them to kill themselves
so what what
what is it about you know these people
that are gonna remain
is this is this a thing where it is a
dangerous thing
or can we just expect that the people
who are disseminating this information
intentionally
know that it's not true they're not
going to act on it they're just trying
to get other people
to act on it what what can we can we
unpack that or or will we not know for a
long time
well so well here's what you're saying
is i think absolutely true
that there are people the the dangerous
ones are the ones manipulating the
information and manipulating the people
but i think there is also recruitment
happening in that way right so
uh alt-right groups white supremacist
groups i think they will
have been and will continue to recruit
people
into their uh fold and i think they will
radicalize these people which would will
be violence right so i mean
i think right i think the fbi has been
pretty plain about that
is that the the number one threat to our
country
and increasingly so is domestic
terrorism from
alt-right groups so i think this does
have that component to it
the scary thing here for me anyway is i
don't think donald trump as much as he
wants to say he's incredibly smart
i don't think he's an incredibly smart
person right so
if you have someone like trump that
comes along who's actually smart
and who's actually a better manipulator
what could he
you know what like really what could
that person
do you know so that's the thing that
worries me
about how much of this infrastructure is
going to still be in place say in 2024
and what type of uh person could come
along
and sort of sort of like a more evil
donald trump
so in other words if a non-buffoon
can can become the the
i'll put it the way i put it on but take
out take over the [ __ ] cult for him
and and and continue this this thing
that that's where it could get [ __ ]
dangerous
is what you're saying right right so so
that is an interesting question
and uh because i think that poses
the actual criminality of it because i
don't think q anon in itself
is a cr is is criminal right i i think
if you want to believe
wild crazy ideas you know certainly you
can believe wild and crazy ideas this is
a free country we're free to believe a
bunch of dumb [ __ ] right
i mean that's part of freedom and if we
think we're gonna stop people from
believing dumb [ __ ] we are out of our
[ __ ] minds
but i do think at some point where like
you're saying before
if you take a white supremacist who is a
professional white supremacist this is
what they make money this is their
living
is to radicalize people criminally
radicalize people
um when that criminal component becomes
part of it
um how does the medical community
because
you know it's different it's different
in the medical community than law
enforcement
how does the medical community deal with
this isn't this isn't just a mental
health thing this
is now has that criminal component to it
i mean
is it beyond mental health mental health
and the mental health infrastructure's
control at that point and it has to be
deal
through law enforcement or what tell us
about that because i think the
criminality portion of it
is we're gonna see this play out in
court with some of these
insurrectionists
and and the people who organized this uh
in particular probably some of these
oath keepers
the three percenters uh uh roger stone i
know has been in the news a lot lately
uh um that he was with the oath keepers
beforehand
um also the proud boys and then even uh
donald trump and some of his allies
allies that are close around him did
they have anything to do with the
organization of the actual insurrection
the criminality of it so so tell me what
what at what point does the medical
health community go well
it is beyond our control at this point
this is a criminal thing you know
speaking of
of radicalizing people i'll tell you and
um there's there's a way that i feel
like the mental health
the medical community might have failed
people in um in a lot of ways these past
couple years
and maybe even longer than that because
for the longest time there's kind of
been like a
uh a credo of you don't take any you
know you don't touch politics right like
it's you don't do that you don't so a
lot of people
were not speaking out um until it was
probably
too late about the kind of disorders
they might see in someone like donald
trump right or about the kind of
disorders
they might see or or the danger
potential
for q anon and so i think the metal
community medical community could have
been
um more outspoken on that
so there's that part of it but
ultimately i think i think it's to a
point where
a lot of this stuff is gonna be um yeah
the justice system is going to have to
figure out a lot of this stuff
because the criminal aspect there's not
much that um
the medical field can do about can do
about that
um and again you cannot so here's the
other thing you cannot
force mental health treatment on anyone
you can try to
but it never works uh you know i've
worked with so many people who were
mandated into treatment
and nothing happens if they don't want
to be there you can't
you know you could you can make somebody
show up uh what is it you you can lead a
horse to water but you can't make them
drink and that's that's so true
well i i i think you're i think you're
right about that
and going back to jonestown comparing uh
you know i know it's not a very good
comparison but
it's one of the best cult like
comparisons that we have
where they followed one individual who
is uh who
you know you said they bonded with and i
think that was part of jonestown as they
were
not only not only emotionally but
physically bonded with this person
because he would
he would do healings with them and all
kinds of crazy stuff now now trump
doesn't have that
that physical bond with these people
where he walked into a crowd and
you know would heal them and things um
but where where
uh jim jones and i think that's how he
got them to move to a different country
because they were physically bonded to
him
um but we had our tarmac moment if you
if you go back and look at the history
of jonestown we had our tarmac moment
with january 6th
um and and i don't think that we've
reached our kool-aid moment here yet
um and i hope there i hope there isn't a
kool-aid moment
uh right you know where these people
decide that it's it's not even worth
um you know continuing at all because
everything they found out is true or
someone tells them
something um so and and i don't know
because
i don't i don't get onto the deep dark
parts of the web and
and look and see what these q and r
people are saying uh i just
i just kind of look at what other people
are saying that they're saying
and what's being reported um so there
might be some deep parts of the web that
uh of this q anon stuff that has already
tried this i don't know
but i don't think we've reached a
kool-aid moment yet and i hope we don't
but uh can you can you
having treated people have you ever seen
someone that was in the state
of a a quote-unquote kool-aid moment and
is that a turning point for some of
these people or is it just
in mass i'm not talking about individual
but in mass right because they are
disseminating this information in mass
you know they're they're
they're eating this stuff uh in a mass
way on these forms so
uh because the dangerous part here for
those people not not for
us as people who don't believe in q anon
i believe the dangerous part for
their mental health and their lives is a
kool-aid moment
right and do we reach a kool-aid moment
or is this a completely different thing
and i'm way off
so those are really good questions that
i wish i had the answer to like i wish i
knew
is this going to go to a a kool-aid
moment and
i haven't had so i've worked with many
people that had psychosis but i've never
worked with someone
that was um sort of active
in any sort of cult right and so i think
that
um i i don't want to speak too much on
uh where that's going i don't know where
that's going you know so i don't want to
pretend like i do
and there could be a kool-aid moment but
i hope that there's not just like you
well i i think there's a lot of stuff to
agree on here and i think
i think uh and you'll probably agree
with me on this too
as we go along um and and the months
tick by here
and especially once we we unpack what
actually happened during january 6th
um and not not only what these people
did but what led them to do this because
you know i had that the the the cua
cuenon shaman or the buffalo guy the guy
with the [ __ ] horns
right right they're right the statement
he made was oh
i felt like i was duped by donald trump
you know he
reached his light switch moment right
where he says he was
duped by donald trump he feels like it
now i said in a video that i made
that's your [ __ ] radar picking up
facts dude
um and i think that's the thing is is
when these people
finally you know start to pick up the
facts and let me tell you something
these people that are sitting in rooms
uh in detention centers with their
lawyer and their lawyers telling them
hey
you're gonna go to prison for a very
long time no matter what here
no matter what we say and what we do
you're going to go to federal prison
and and that can hit someone in the face
very hard and change
and have a light switch if that's the
truth um we've seen it with the jenna
ryan
um you know we haven't heard much from
her lately because she did the whole
well i don't feel guilty because donald
trump told me that i
i could do it well we haven't heard a
lot from her lately and that's probably
because her attorney said you need to
sit down and shut up because
you're making it worse for yourself
because our only defense here
because really their only defense is
that they were duped that they
were literally convinced that that this
was the right thing to do
now what that means in court is they
will have to prove
that if they go down the road of a trial
which
what i'm what i'm trying to get out here
is that we will have
evidence that will be public that will
show
what these people believe how they
believe that the timeline that they
believed it in and what made them act
um and maybe just maybe maybe just maybe
when that information gets out there
maybe some of these people that are
going wow
i believe the same thing right you know
i think i think it could have a light
switch moment
for them as well and and um you know i
i i don't know i don't know that q anon
uh is a long-term threat to our
democracy i don't i really don't even
see
it uh honestly as a short-term threat to
our democracy itself
i see it as a as a threat to our
education more than anything
and to stall our education in this
country because and and
i think this idea to ignore it is really
stupid too
we shouldn't ignore this thing we should
get it out in the open we should give it
daylight uh because i believe that
sunlight is the best disinfectant
i believe it gives an opportunity for
these people to go
wow you know the people that are like
i'm not q but they believe everything
that q says
right because because a lot of these
people aren't
aren't getting this information from cue
themselves they're getting it from their
neighbors
or their their parishioners at church or
their friends on facebook
who were posting a q meme that doesn't
say q on it right
right so they're getting these ideas and
they're they're they're in this mental
state
of q anon without even knowing it so
i think i think we got a lot a long ways
to go to unpack this cue stuff but again
i i don't think it goes anywhere
because uh you know this march 4th thing
they took out a sovereign citizen
theory if you guys have ever heard of
that the sovereign citizen [ __ ] is way
out there too
but what they did is they plucked out
the thing that they need to
move the goal post put it in their q
anon soup
and now now it's part of their theory
right and i believe
after march 4th is over and they're like
well there's nothing of that
they just pluck something out of another
conspiracy theory put it in their q anon
soup and stir it up a bit
and bam you're right back and moving the
goal post down to a different date
and i think the next date will probably
probably be the primaries because that's
next year so something's gonna happen
next year and then when that doesn't
happen it'll be 2024 and
but but i i think the good part is here
when we go through these criminal trials
um uh either with the insurrectionists
or the people who organize this
i believe this country is going to have
some really good information some really
good evidence of what happened
how it happened and how they were
radicalized because
ultimately i think that's the dangerous
part about this q and on stuff is people
can be radicalized just like they were
radicalized
some of these young men were radicalized
to go over and be a part of isis
it's the exact same thing these people
are terrorists they're right wing
delusional terrorist they believe
delusional stuff
that people have deluded them to believe
and if they
can be coerced to act violently on these
delusions
that's the dangerous part and to assume
that some of these people are any any
different than than these
then how they radicalize some of these
young men to go over and participate in
isis and the caliphate over there
you're absolutely a bonehead it is the
exact same thing
it's just it's just from a different
angle from a different group trying to
get them to radicalize
to to stop or kill a different group of
people
and to think that that the threats of
them killing
public officials is not real i think
that's really stupid too we need to take
that
very seriously that's why it concerns me
that
you know we we scoff this off as mental
health right but
everyone has mental health problems
everybody this is this isn't this isn't
a
a you you have a low iq so you're more
susceptible which that may be the case
but everyone has mental health problems
i mean
you think of a physical athlete a
physical athlete
can sprain their ankle they could be in
the best physical shape of their life
and sprain an ankle a a a a nfl
quarterback can be in the best physical
health
of their entire [ __ ] life and they'll
never be more athletic than in that
moment
and be hit on the skull with another
helmet
and be concussed and not be that athlete
that they were
anymore right from that point forward
they may appear it
it may seem that way but in all reality
they're not so we're not all immune from
mental health
problems um and i think we all have a
certain degree of mental illness and
you could probably speak more of that
but we don't have enough time to speak
on that
but maybe we'll do another show on that
because i i really truly believe that a
lot of people
um don't they take for granted their
mental health
and that oh i feel good today but it can
take one little light bulb that that
switches on or off
and you're absolutely in that state so
totally agree
i think i thank you for coming on again
matt uh i really do
and i hope you can come on again and we
can talk about this some more maybe
maybe in a few months we'll know a
little more uh
we'll have a little more insight maybe
more of these people that's well right
right well you know i think there's
going to be a lot of events
that as they move these goalposts and as
they say this and say that and it all
falls apart
i think it will really it will really
help the country understand
why this is bone-headed stuff to believe
and i think
it'll be more reason for us to go well
that's what that was that's what that
was because
we won't know it until it happens right
we won't know it until it happens
and i think uh i thank you for coming on
and hopefully we can
have you on in the future and uh don't
be shy
okay if you have something to say and
you want to say it
let me know and i'll uh get you back on
the podcast thanks matt for coming oh
and i'm gonna tell everyone go follow
him on tick tock
because this guy has go watch his videos
on this stuff
because he does a really good job of
breaking some of this stuff down in 60
seconds but i wanted to have a longer
platform to explain so thank you matt
for coming on
go follow him on tick tock we'll talk to
you later buddy have a good one
thanks so there you have it
we fixed the entire q problem all in an
hour
right no this this is not going to be
this is not going to be an overnight fix
we're not going to fix this thing in an
hour
but we need to keep talking about it uh
and we need to talk about it in a way
that is going to be productive uh you
know and and i think that the most
productive way to talk about it is a
mental health state in this country what
is crazy to me
what is [ __ ] crazy to me about this
whole thing
the whole entire thing is the people
actually fighting for mental health care
for these people
are the [ __ ] people that voted
against donald trump
they're the ones who want to make sure
that these people have
some mental [ __ ] health care in this
country
we're the ones fighting for it that's
the craziest part to me
so hopefully hopefully we can get mental
health
healthcare
in this country more access to it and
these people
um can see the light that hey this stuff
is bogus and wrong and dumb
and move on to a different
radicalization of the right wing because
we're not going to get rid of the white
right wing in this country not anytime
soon we never get rid of the right wing
so
maybe they'll move on to the next uh
theory but it would be less dangerous
than it is
the way it is now but i do agree with
matt when he says that
uh trump being off the internet and
trump not having the influence
uh does help uh and and his little
letter to mitch mcconnell doesn't
demonstrate that any better
because it feels like to me that his
letter against mitch mcconnell
was this letter that he saved up all the
mean tweets that he wanted to tweet
about
mitch mcconnell and he wrote them down
on a sheet of paper uh
and and decided to just compile them
into one big letter
so hopefully he can continue to uh
get get his influence knocked down and
down and these people can
finally figure out the light and the
where they're going but in the meantime
in the meantime you know [ __ ] them
thanks for joining us
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them